hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar sip that initiative and
validation of high throughput methods to
characterize compound effects in human
IPSC derive cardio myocyte and christi
Joel of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab herbs and brought to you by
molecular devices and eurofins discovery
to learn more please visit molecular
devices calm and eurofins discovery
services calm
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
view of trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or let us know
you're experiencing a problem by using
that ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
best offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speakers dr. Rangi
Ranganathan senior scientists at Europe
and discovery
dr. Pineda turkey at mongol senior
scientist group leader of cell day
screening at europe and discovery
dr. Oksana Cherenko senior research
scientist at molecular devices and ms
Carroll Crittenden applications
scientist at molecular devices for
complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
our agenda for today will include renji
discussing the importance and challenges
of cardiac safety evaluation and how the
cipa initiative offers new ways of
testing potential compounds then Pineda
will discuss ways to analyze calcium
flux data from cardio toxicity studies
from the cipa 28 compounds Oksana will
follow that up with additional data from
the new flipper penta assays and finally
Carol will discuss the new features of
the Slipper Penta system including
high-speed camera which enables more
detailed cardio myocyte and neuronal
data as well as peak Pro analysis
options that were used for data analysis
throughout this presentation and finally
we will conclude with our Q&A sessions
our speakers will now begin their
presentations
hi my name is Benji dengan often first
of all on behalf of your friends I would
like to extend a warm welcome for this
webinar wherever you are and I'm going
to I have about 20 years experience in
the cardiac safety evaluation so I would
say it's with you some of the you know
the challenges how the recent technology
is pushing the boundary to make the drug
discovery with more efficient education
so the outline for my talk is going to
be first we are going to set the tone
for understanding the rest of the talk
by describing in a warning to cardiac
depolarizing current or Plata phase or
repolarizing currents of a cardiac
action potential how it is kinetically
keep you interval and because these are
the basic parameters that are going to
be measured even in the preclinical and
clinical drug discovery process so and
then I will briefly talk about the drug
industry PT prolongation and to start
the pond
what other parameter for these deadly
disease and the current safety paradigm
outlined in ITSs 7b and yeap 14 I'm
talking about from 2000 to 2015
these four the guidelines used for drug
discovery and there are there were some
issues in there which is summarizing
this in this point there is the
surrogate endpoints human eater global
delivered gene block and keyd
prolongation was used as a surrogate
endpoints not the florid merit the
Prasad rates because the facade is very
rare to see in clinical trials so they
have to look for surrogate endpoints and
that's how they started using third
block and PT prolongation the you see
here is the third block and kicky
prolong it is very sensitive but it's
not very specific for predicting Flores
near risk and I also want to talk a
little bit that the process starts with
the QT prolongation but not all TT
prolongation in incentives are so from
the get-go of these guidelines we know
the decks were against the disco
and you know all the 15 years they
figure it'll be the consortium have came
up together and try to push the
initiative based on some external
evidence which I will briefly talk about
in the sonic talk the initiative is to
facilitate the adoption of a new pattern
for assessment of clinical potential of
Prasad not method exclusively by a whole
block are not about like et pollination
and then I'm going to step in a little
bit about how Europeans join discipline
assertive and contradicted you know for
the height of the platform by scanning
the 20th drugs that you know span high
intermediate and local third risk and
then the separately tried the multi
electrode array using IPS II induced
pluripotent stem cell of course human
cardiomyocytes in a multi electrode
array with specific blockers for you
know some of the depolarizing and
repolarizing currents which I've shared
with you and then comes the my colleague
from San Diego will talk about how to
use the flipper as a as a as a tool to
help discovery check out the guidelines
and the next slide here I'm going to
just summarize the principal terms so
cardiac membranes are very highly
polarized what do I mean by that if you
look at the cardiac cell the inside of a
cell is very negative close to minus
eighty millivolts compared to the
outside of the cell which is close to
zero and so and also if you look at the
concentration gradient for calcium and
sodium they are much higher than the
outside of the cell in the inside and
the voltage-gated channels are you know
membrane gated and they are poor on the
membrane so when they open the
concentration gradient depending on the
concentration gradient the sodium and
calcium build in this case will be fall
into the cell and because it's the
reverse for potassium when the channel
for a sentinel opens it flows out of the
cell why they put the diagram because
it's the milady millivolt when the
sodium and calcium
this positive act go in and they
neutralize the negative charge and there
will become more more positive whereas
in the production channel open the
positives will go out then they try to
bring the best importance of Mack back
to the -80
resting membrane potential and that's
what I'm going to try to solve here in
this cartoon so the fast way speed the
depolarizing current of the currents
here is the black line is the baseline
and the blue current is the is the
bottom of the base plan that that means
it is falling into the cell so these
positive sodium and calcium charges
flowing neutralize the minus eighty
millivolts and that's what you see here
in this left-hand panel that minus 80
was the sodium channel and this goes to
my plus 40 and then comes a calcium
that's where the plateau phase is where
the begin will and outward the
depolarizing ripple in current are more
or less similar a same amplitude so it's
a kind of plotted face and by the time
the depolarizing current comes both the
sodium and calcium contribute and slower
they inactivated they will not open
unless they come back to the minus
eighty and then we come back the cycle
continues again so then comes the the
rest of the potassium channels and
purple that particular importance is the
IKr
this is what the hell can is called this
is a beautiful current the way it is set
up in nature is amazing to see that it
opens only at the V polarizing stage and
the maximum contribution comes at that
stage and that's why it is very
important for the depolarizing case so
now we have established the depolarizing
what is depolarizing means what is the
plateau phase means what is the v
polarizing current means we can go on to
the next level and a large one simple
thing for people that deflecting current
is the one which triggers the cardiac
muscle contraction and then the
repolarization current is the one which
relaxes the muscle and that's how one
type of project [ __ ] happens just in
case if you don't know about that
so this slide you know if you record the
cardiac action potential from different
parts of the cardiac tissue this is
color coded to percent and so the
propagation of the cardiac electric
signal
is from the top to the bottom and so
this starts boom cardiac action will
starts first and at the end sat at the
bottom with the ventricular muscle so if
you align them and start submit them and
that's what you get as a normal ECG and
this is given in the necklace atlas of
human physiology page 17 if you want to
read more about it so the P wave comes
from the atrium and the QRS comes from
the ventricular depolarization remember
the left ventricle is the most powerful
muscle and it pumps the blood for the
rest of the body so the QRS and the T is
the depolarization so the TT interval is
the one which messes the left ventricle
function particularly the pumping of
blood to all of the body so which by
establishing death we are going to go to
a to stick to the problem which happened
in the early part of on the late part of
1990s 1998 and 2000 that's the time that
the drug induced to kick you prolong
isn't what it was absorbed and and they
also figured it out it was the whole
village was doing it and and the you
know these the treasure frequencies were
far too low to be detected in clinical
trials so it was only found in phase
four after the drugs were approved it
was out in the open market and then they
saw the facade then they had a good job
so within the two years they had a visit
of five compounds definitely in certain
role as the midsole grabber fluxing into
the drive now let's let's give some
thoughts to the diploma industry so they
spent ten years developing each drug
candidate and about 1 million dollars
and suddenly they had to take it back
and five drugs having to be drawn so the
whole carmine mystery was taken up and
then all the the pharma industry FDA and
other guys got together and they found
the other initiative that's called the
SMD in 2000 so what do we learn from
this on five drugs they are all total
nerve blocker
very highly selective in the form of the
dynamic range what I mean that is when
you take a drug for a disease you know
it's the same concentration it
definitely cubes your drug it also
blocks the fur so you don't want to die
by
but blocking it heard and that's why
they did draw the dryer so and then they
also knew that the got the diesel of his
new there is more clear markers for
these problems they suggested use heard
and Qt and this was introduced in 2000
and if you go back to next slides how
her induced the QT prolongation as we
talked about herb is the human heater
Google's liquor Gina funny name
it's a potassium current the IKS stands
for ice 4i for current K for potassium
are for the repolarization of the
correct action potential this channel is
very unique it has the the insect or is
very unique consent that send it
promised Leslie binds structurally
different compounds so this is a very
efficient of the drugs has some of her
block so there was a very big problem
for the drugging film industry this
inhibition what happens is as we talked
about in the action potential cartoon
but when it's been the the whole Channel
current is plugged the repoer is a text
time no time to come to do it so there
is a delay in repolarization and that
can reflect in QT prolongation and
that's okay but it's only when you see
this early after depolarization and
there is a prolongation and at that time
and he changes in the invalid output
current because of the plateau phase the
resistance is very high than rest of any
phase of the action potential
any small change in the current of the
plateau phase can induce eav most
notably the Catherine current IV the
sodium blade current which it forgot to
mention in the last line
so this EA D is very rare and that's the
one that triggers the mechanism but to
slot so with one of them setting up for
the death of the Tarkan's pearl plug is
okay
keep long is okay but is the Prasad or
EAD that's not okay so if you are
blocking her looking for her block and Q
deep language and you are already you
know failing most of the drug candidates
right so that is the issue for the
former and become blame former because
they spend a lot of money and time
so what I did was the jab you know the
hurt it became more about the former
Cardinal about 1996 they stopped any
drug that blocked heard at a particular
range you know they have a kind of a
safety ratio and in that safety ratio is
trust they stopped the development on
solid rock so when they use that
approach in the 1996 there was fast
hydrants withdrawn in the five year time
period from 2005 and every five interval
you can see the number of compounds
getting with John is coming low and low
and from 2000 onwards there was no drugs
done because of the torchon it was a
very good sections but at what cost
and that's what you're going to see here
in the next slide because the key keep
elongation is not always rich to premier
and the also long helping you be sent
leads to PT prolongation but it now is
always equal Detroit Nia so and we have
some specific cases of drugs to like
Prozac about a billion dollar drug is an
antidepressant it blocks work probably
but at the same count innocent blood
calcium to similarly development to the
venison is another case where it blocks
health as well as the the lecture in
current the the calcium current the
lecture him current all the players at
the plot of phase and that's why
blocking these two parents they are very
cardiac saved in addition to blocking
hug and innocent people anguish and
that's what its own here at the bottom
Thailand figure the left panel is for
only help block drugs only so for the
carbon gives with three channels sodium
calcium and Mary and the sodium and
cancer not blocked about the health is
blocked any block the heard you have the
prolongation of the keep the the action
potential duration and because the
calcium the let Colin could be active it
can induce not all the time at certain
times when that conditions of an IPL
these currents can induce the EAD
that can lead into the prasada pond
which is very detrimental to other
people now let's take a look at the the
balanced ion channel block there a drug
at simply plug on your client it not
only blocks hurt it also blocks calcium
it may also block the ledge
current then see what happens here yes
you do see a prolong it's an in action
potential duration yes of quality CDT
the QT prolongation but he never will
see any too far so we knew about this in
the late in the early 2000 or 2007 fires
so that's what triggered for the new
initiative and it took a while for all
of us to come together in 2011 at 12 and
they proposed this comprehensive in
vitro chlorination deployed near as a
Shabbat personal so it has four panels
you know listed here the first place to
look at multiple ionic currents drug
effects are in vitro Suslov drug effects
and multiple ionic currents and all
these effects are integrated into in
silikal computer modeling to predict
premiere risk all right this is more or
less an validated and so they will post
a nightmare risk is validated then they
won't look for us look for unwanted or
unanticipated effect on individual
stenciled inner curve into the
cardiomyocytes from human and that data
will help to determine whether there is
any effects or not then you go for the
the Phase one clinical trial in this
year what we are looking for is again
they are going to look for exposure
response analysis most of the individual
people will know of customers and
response Marisa dick the animal in vivo
animal that they use different kinds of
technology but they now come to the
conclusion that expose the response that
is for any time point when the vessel
they affect their low what if the
concentration of the drug that plasma so
that way they can figure out what's
happened for the QT interval even in the
kitchen through all they're not only
measuring the huge interval we are
measuring this you know they miss
publication if you have more interesting
can go look at it
then from this part of this part is
called JQ t peak and then a TP to TN the
drugs that block the calcium and the
sodium current they do not have any
effect on the g8 to T peak and also
called a liberalism change but the help
only block will have an
the TP to the TN so they have added more
parameters they have discovered the drug
discovery more efficient way so what we
are going to summarize on this
particular slide taking messages you
successful this initiatives such as well
she probably enable you know create a
pathway for tribes with the third block
and Kiki prolongation to advance the top
intensive ECG monitoring in Phase three
trials
let's call the turkey cheat on that just
take a lot of time and money so you
don't have to do that anymore if simple
passes through and also the second
important factor is that you can enable
updating drug levels to be more
information about fluoride liquid rather
than a general QT prolongation this is
all helping the pharma industry and also
bringing more drugs into the to the
human population now [ __ ] life I am
going to explain how we open join the TS
se in a calculated consortium and the KC
and the FDA had to be screen sub came in
2015 was that Yungas is you know
different people different groups
different platforms but use blinded
compounds except from one source and
which standard you will all use
candidates as they protocols to collect
data in their spirit platform
unnecessary but the FDA and never look
at the data for you know how good is
this deeper disability across the
different sites and platforms and here
we let and of some of the compounds
which you have very low risk and
intermediate to flood risk and high
profile risk you know I'm not going to
go to the data here we have a sent all
the data to the FDA and you know which
is a lot of website about all these the
concentration as well and everything
what I'm saying here is that we be put a
premium on our vehicle control data that
is why do we do that because we miss the
time make time match the vehicle control
to the compound medicine to so that if
you add only wake up there is no effect
on the baseline but if you have a drug
at the same time concentration they have
a claim dose response car without any
effect on the baseline
and so you have less confidence in your
IQ Tavella destination here in this case
it is on down central citron is activity
is close to one micromolar and this is
very close to what we assume with the
rest of the rupestre and similarly for
the sodium 1.5 it is specific for the
cardiac s a cardiac surgeon said I'm
sorry
and here is a peak current is measured
and I'm sewing a speaker and I think
tank IV mother put this lid current as
you know in the slides - you know - all
on me with the slack with it with a lot
of data what is those here again is that
it's a stable baseline and clean those
responds and you can take the I take 50
value very clearly at any time for
coming to calcium we get the misses with
using simple protocol if you had a
tremendous run down more than 40 to 50
percent on bond which is not a good key
for other assets so we had to take the
protocol and use a different day to
bring the control bring the run down to
minimal like 15 or 20 percent so that's
why climb this is not a secure protocol
under the specific reason why we did it
and and we also use the specific
blockers if it depended kinda thing to
solve the reproducibly is very close to
each other the minimal run down and so
the to the work unheard results in too
many scripts in the works with the FDA
I'm going to read this but it's in there
if you want to look at it and if you
know it's going to be published in the
future hopefully we'll get more detail
on this and so what aspect of the the
supplies is using you know induced
pluripotent stem so the record in my
sights
obviously from heaven as an immature
model to study call it excessively
you know of super compounds for that we
use the MEA that's the bottle signal and
Canada used the flipper correct expert
calcium signal s a simpler more about
the next few slides this is the nice
turn platform listed here on the top and
the carton here compares what he said to
the ECG the teacher in Kavala to do the
field the consideration and this 513
spike is the cardiac depo
signal and the TV is the cardiac
repolarization signal connection
cardiomyocytes and the the the period
between the repo depolarization and
repolarization between sodium pipe and
TV is the plateau phase mainly coming
from chasm channel and this is very
important in a widely for selling
features is that it is done at
physiological temperature as it's in the
body body temperature is an integrated
measurement of all the action instead
and we can translate that and you can
look for check for an answer
anticipated our unwanted effects so here
again you know the Cree three critical
phases of the correct safety cardiac
depolarization plateau phase and
repolarization beyond were coming from
sodium calcium and her channel or
potassium channels so beautiful sitting
next to living blocker which is where it
can become swollen channel it decreases
the amplitude for cardiac depolarization
as one will expect without doing
anything the rest of the tool the
plateau phase are occurring the people
repolarization on the other hand we used
the United opinion which is very
specific as in channel it shortens the
duration between the depolarization and
repolarization and that's what we marked
DDR remarks lady the TV star moving
towards to the lab close to the
depolarization in names field potential
division began shortened it's the
reverse for the front Dockerty 40:31 it
promptly the repolarization day it
becomes longer and longer sometimes you
can even see earlier people year
depolarization in this in these valves
so with much detail i will exist
summarized here what i have seen with
the mea parameters the key three
parameters are you know the deep period
even any effect on the deep period and
in the field but in the duration
and spike amplitude the big video takes
the caption you know calcium blockers
treatment in subdivision again you can
block you can see what the calcium and
and and and and blogosphere so let's go
through quickly the ephors Beckman is a
head Barker it pretty but it blocks a
bit period and the field for the
duration is not much effect on spike
amplitude the DC stands for a friend
reject correction which is for big
period if the any change in the big
period can be corrected so comparing
apples to apples in one way and the
mixolydian is a sodium channel blocker
did not have anything for either the
three others but only had an effect
that's my character which is the before
didn't peak and naturally can do some
cardiac cath internal blocker the beat
period we can decrease that means they'd
had more beats per period and you can
also see that that reduce the duration
in both cases without miss affecting
spike amplitude on the other hand and
with the major control that match the
duration of these Cup on paracin is
given as a control to so what kind of
effector you would see and that is far
from my side of the talk and I'm going
to hand it over to my colleague from San
Diego
Pineda please take away yeah thank you
Renji so for the next part I will be
presenting the application of IPS V
derived cardiomyocytes as a model to
evaluate potential cardiotoxicity of
compounds using flipper for this study
we use calcium flux as a to monitor
contraction and relaxation of cardio
myocyte
we detect either increased or decreased
levels of calcium ions using
calcium-sensitive dye the dye binds
calcium ions in cytoplasm as displayed
in the cartoon on the left and elicits
for us and signals that can be captured
by a high-speed CCD Camel are in flipper
so the detected for it sends signals
from the calcium flux essays represent
intracellular calcium oscillations in
order to understand what happens to
cardio myocyte
a burn compound treatment I use Pippo
shown here on the top left panel which
is an add-on up screen works to extract
kinetic parameters from the traces pay
pro assigns Peaks which display which
are displayed as blue dots it can also
set the baseline and the triggered
levels as shown in the rate and green
lines the increase in fluorescence
signal corresponds to contraction
whereas the decrease corresponds to
relaxation of cardiomyocytes we can
monitor in real time and overtime in
this example the second panel on the
left is the pretreatment trace then the
cells were treated with compounds and
incubated for 30 minutes and then we
read shown in the third panel on the
left there are several parameters that
we can extract from the traces using
peak Pro from our experience mean peak
rate calcium transient duration 90 of
CTD 90 and peak spacing a Prezy are
pretty consistent across the whole cell
plate and from experiment to experiment
so we go with these parameters to plot
our dose response curves as shown on the
right to calculate ic50 these are more
examples of cardiomyocytes treated with
ISO per terminal which is an agonist of
beta adrenergic receptor that can
increase the heart rate the trace exhale
buds increased mean peak rate and
decrease CTD 90 and peak spacing these
parameters correlate with the effect of
isoproterenol as you can see the next
one is estamos all which is categorized
in intermediate risk of GDP estimate all
is an earth blogger and causes QT
prolongation from the trace the mean
peak rate is decreased
whereas CTD 90 and peak spacing are
increased which are characteristics of
people engaging
due to blockage of repolarization by
earth the next one is so tall which is
categorized in the high risk for TDP so
tall is a beta blogger it can also
prolong repolarization by blocking the
rapid component of delayed rectifier
potassium current from our as a total
treated cells exhale decreased mean T
trait but increased CTD 90 and peak
spacing showing the characteristic of
people elongation as well for these
three parameters our data points are
quite tight as shown in these three
graphs and the blue dot they are the 30
minutes post treatment that you can
compare to the pretreatment so you can
clearly see these data points they are
clearly distinguishable between before
and after the drug treatment and these
scatter plots demonstrate that our
calcium flux assays is uniform and
consistent the observed effects are also
correlated with actions of the drugs my
assessments of super compounds will be
discussed by Oksana
get so much-- Pineda so in the beginning
of my part of presentation I would like
to show you a video
so on this video you can see those
flashes up and down so they a cure when
cells contract synchronously and calcium
goes in and out of this cells
intracellular cells storages and calcium
dye get brighter or dollar in
accordingly the concentration of calcium
in a cell so you can see control
recording and also you can see changes
in a pattern for cells treated with
epinephrine
verapamil so this epinephrine
you can see increase of amplitude and
frequency and we'll verify meal you can
see decrease of amplitude
so as shown on a video so I would like
to describe what is our si is doing so
on this slide you can see that we
actually absorb in cells which are
plated in a culture and those cells are
cardiomyocytes IPC derived
cardiomyocytes and you can see them in
10x magnification and when you put a dye
on it you you can observe those fluxes
up and down which you can measure with
our instrument clipper Penta and also
you can record and characterize those
sticks
so for cardiotoxicity evaluation of 28
cheaper compounds we have taken
measurements of calcium oscillations and
it seems like a promising method for
toxicity assessment the evaluated set of
super compounds which categorized as a
high medium or low risk categories
according to clinical data reviews I
sell cardiomyocytes to from CDI which
were cultured as recommended for six
days and then loaded with early talks
calcium die and 3° compounds so the
recording could be done at different
time points so starting from 15 minutes
after compound addition but also
additional recording would be taken at
30 60 90 up to 24 hours also you can do
long-term compound treatment in this
case you treat with compounds first and
then add the dye to the cells and record
the effects of those compounds with
slipper Penta system so in this slide
you can see a screenshot from a slipper
instrument so here we've tested high
risk compounds those compounds were
tested in quadruplicate and you can see
the effect of compounds increased to the
top of the blade where it was increase
in concentration so
you can see also some negative control
switch amoxicillin and biotin on a right
side of a panel where you can see no
impact on a pattern but many compounds
which considered high risk show very
severe changes in a pattern so the most
notably you can see prolongation of the
pigs and also you can see some secondary
pigs appearance in addition to this you
see changes in amplitude between
frequency also regularity up to complete
stop of bitten range so here you can
present individual patterns so in M on
this slide you can see in blue the
control pattern and in red the pattern
affected is indicated compounds so you
can see those different patterns
modifications which I just described you
can see prolongation of Peaks is as the
Missal you can see increase or decrease
of amplitude like this as a professional
you can see increase of amplitude and
frequency with others you may see
decrease of amplitude and frequency you
can see increase in between Peaks also
irregularities and you can see stop of
oscillation in some concentrations so
those typical escalation pattern could
be measured and characterized so our
software is able to detect main Peaks
and also secondary peaks it can also
measure the amplitude frequency raise
and decay time of peaks and it can
characterize distance between Peaks and
also regularity or irregularity buttons
so here you can see some additional
patterns so you can see combination of
different effects for example you can
see irregularity and appearance of
additional Peaks also you can see this
pattern which we call like stop
oscillation where you can see
decreasing amplitude and also highly
increased frequency which actually cause
stop of oscillation so this our software
you can characterize those Peaks and
derive number of measurements those
descriptors include account peak
frequency you can count main ticks and
also secondary peaks and number of
secondary peaks fermentx you can count
distance between Peaks amplitude and
also raise in decay time so this number
of descriptors can characterize all
complexity of pattern you can observe so
some of those readouts have a good dose
this pendants pattern like for example
on this slide you can see monotonal
decrease or increase of peak frequency
also you can observe monotonal increase
or decrease of amplitude but some other
readouts may be non monotonic so for
monotonal descriptor you can calculate
eg 50s for non monitor nose you can
actually calculate minimum concentration
at which the change occurs so in this
example you can see high risk medium
risk and low risk compound and changes
in peak count over concentration so
notably high risk and medium risk
compound caused mostly decrease on
bitten rate and low dis compound many of
those actually cause increased bitten
rate so you can characterize a different
measurements and calculate effective
concentrations for different
measurements and you can use multi
parametric approach the toxicity
assessment so interestingly we try to
look at this
concentration dependencies the way that
we would normalize it to see max so the
actual concentration of compound in a
blood and we also look at different
readouts actually effective
concentrations or eg fifties for
different readouts and what was
interesting is that for high-risk
compound we observe that those changes
especially increase of DIC prolongation
or appearance of secondary peaks appear
at concentration which are comparable
for c-max for medium raise compounds you
can see those changes appear at
concentration about tenfold higher than
c-max and for low-risk compounds you
don't see any of those effects at all
like increase of the prolongation or
appearance of secondary peaks while you
still can see stop beating or increase
fibrillation or irregularity or change
in amplitude in different concentrations
so that would suggest that pick
prolongation and also appearance of
secondary peaks may be the most
important parameters for prediction of
potential torsade de pointes in addition
to characterization of isolation pattern
we also follow this high content imaging
to characterize changes or in the self
viability and cytotoxicity effects for
example out of those 28 compounds we had
several which had cytotoxic effects so
this is kind of important to see whether
changes caused by compound are due to
cytotoxicity or changes in isolation
pattern so we use image express
instrument for this purpose but any
imaging instrument could be used so and
we characterize the number of life and
dead cells and also cell spreading and
intensity for mobile
two markers so in a conclusion since
like the essay is very sensitive for
detection of various compound effects on
cardiomyocytes and this effects can be
measured and evaluated by Peak Pro
software and most notably EDD occurrence
and pick prolongation apparently the
most distinctive and predictable
measurements for torsade de pointes so
now I will transfer to Carol who can
tell more about the instrument and
software
so I this is Carol and I'm going to be
talking about using the flipper Penta
system for cardiotoxicity assessment as
well as some of the other things that
the flipper can do and we kind of look
at it as another two more additions to
the family of things that can be done
with slipper
so the flipper pension system has an
unmatched flexibility it's been around
for more than twenty years and it has
grown as the technology and industry has
grown as well and it's flexible because
you can change heads you can change LEDs
and emission filters for different
wavelengths you can have a format of a
stay flexibility if you want you to sell
suspension system it has a sensitivity
flexibility with the cameras we offer
two main cameras one is a standard EMC
CD camera and then our newest flipper
Penta option is the field upgradeable
and it's also a hundred Hertz option
that still has luminescence capability
and using this camera you're able to do
peak Pro calcium oscillation
measurements and then also with
automation it works beautifully and the
nice thing about flipper is that you can
start if you're in 96-well format you
can grow as your assays grow and add
things in the field as well the newest
features of the flipper Penta system is
the high speed camera as well as the
screen works pro 2 software module which
is good for Cal analysis of calcium
oscillation peak characteristics and it
has a difference in temporal resolution
so so most of the standard cameras would
give you a analysis that looks like this
and this is at 8 8 images taken per
second or 8 Hertz and you don't
necessarily get enough detail in the
peak to see what's going on and this is
the same well same cells at 30 Hertz
using the new camera and as you can see
you it's easy
to identify both the peaks as well as
the secondary events involved flippered
Penta system is able to do the assays of
your choice for small molecule screening
it's the standard for GPCR essays any
other calcium ligand gated ion channels
other calcium assays we have a fear of
to assay it can do Corin assays which is
a luminescent assay we can do membrane
potential assays we have a potassium
assay and also for toxicology screening
which we've been talking about here
today we have the cardio myocyte toxic
toxicity sa measuring calcium
oscillations in cardiomyocytes as well
as a neuronal toxicity sa as well we
didn't talk about that here but we have
other interest information about that
and more we can do bred assays we can do
all kinds of other dye assays and you
can look at oscillation in spheroids as
well
so the calcium oscillation analysis in
peak pro 2 gives you a number of
parameters that you can look at the
characterize your Peaks we still are
carrying the peak Pro one module it's
available and then we have the pink pro
2 and our sonic gave a good description
of all of the different characteristics
of the calcium oscillation Peaks to be
able to identify with ease the screen
works screen basically looks like this
you can look at the detail screen you've
got your selected compounds that you're
looking at the control screen to
identify the wells and parameters and
controls of the peak analysis as well as
a chart for looking at all the different
parameters which is easily exportable
and then you can form your graphs and
shown here are three different
characteristics firm a one of the higher
seat bud 28 risk compounds a stem easel
and you're looking at change in peak
rate with concentration as well as peak
amplitude as well as the mean peak decay
time from ninety percent to 10 percent
so that's easily done and the benefits
of the flipper pension system which is
our newest offering is we have the
hundred Hertz camera which enables new
biology and a better understanding of
both neurons and cardiomyocytes easy to
switch to luminescence and easy to
switch to all the regular acids that the
flipper has always done and then we have
the greatly enhanced peak
characterization of calcium assays with
the peak pro 2 software so I'm just
going to give a quick summary
renji gave us a good perspective on the
importance of drug safety and CP 28 and
methods of detection and analysis and
the correlation of calcium oscillation
EFA's MEA and the clinical c-max was
discussed by both Oksana and Renji and
IPSC cardio myocyte
cow
'i'm oscillation measurements using the
flipper penta to clench a system and the
screen works Peak Pro to software so I
want to thank you on behalf of the four
speakers and we're going to turn it over
for questions and answers
Thank You Carol and thank you to all our
speakers for their informative
presentations we will now start the live
tiny portion of our webinar now if you
have a question you would like to ask
our speakers please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for okay now let's get started um I'll
come and let's start with you do you
need viable cardio myocyte cells for
your assay and if so how do you obtain
them
so this is pretty easy question because
like you can derive your own IPC derive
cardiomyocytes but we have taken
advantage of companies who actually do
it professionally so we collaborated the
most and work with the CDI through GP
and CDI company so we get sales from
them and there are also other vendors
like n cardia or demonics where you can
get some models as well
thank you never ng let's come over to
you for this next question have you
tested the 28 simple reference drugs in
the MEA platform and if yes what was the
productivity
yes you know the super 20 D has been
done and I even like three or four years
back as a few publications came out too
on the density of this meas a so we have
what we have done is we focused on only
on the parameters which is very
pertinent to the cardiac safety for
example the cardiac depolarization and
repolarization and butterface and
weaving you know focused on that
inhibitors fast but we've been
collecting data on this 28 just to
understand how the system works so it is
in the works
thank you now Carol I this question
would be for you what is the highest
frame rate for the flipper CCD camera so
the highest room frame rate for that
high-speed camera on the foot by Penta
is 100 Hertz or 100 images per second
Thank You frenzy let's pop back over to
you this next question is for you it was
mentioned in the beginning of the
presentation that HG RG + QT
prolongation were very sensitive but not
very specific do cardiomyocytes give us
the boost in specificity that HG RG + QT
lack yes this is a good question but
there's a see the the bottom line of
using cardiomyocytes the mainly
distinguish between heavenly blockers
are balanced on channel blockers for
example if it blocks knowledge into her
core calcium or her gand leg sodium
current you can see that clearly in
korea myocytes
I say em yes okay thank you
now next question Carol let's go back to
you how does the camera work does it
take an image record the whole plate or
specific Wells so the camera is focused
on the bottom of the wells in all of the
plate and that would be a ninety it can
be a 96 or a 384 or 1536 plate we are
have a technology that will find the
center of the plate and record from that
section for all of those wells in each
plate at the same time so you can crunch
through a lot of data quickly
thank you renji when are the new
protocols expected to go into effect
with FDA and or EMA I think that they
are in the final stages you know I mean
having said that they keep pushing the
deadlines are the guidelines every year
so I think it's going to be this year
2020 but you know it all depends on all
the consortiums
we have to come together and agree on it
there's not a simple process of a few
people agree together and say yes let's
go over this this is a global process
it's not only FDA the European guidance
and the Japanese guidelines and the
pharma industry everybody has to come
together and agree to it so I will you
know I cannot say a clear answer but it
is coming thanks Randy now Oksana what
is your experience with studio I sells
cardiomyocytes too as compared with the
old product cardio myocyte do you see
fast appearance of spontaneous beating
and cardio myocyte
too
yes so actually if you work with
cardiomyocyte too you can see the bit in
the next day definitely the day after so
they get mature pretty fast and they
much easier to work with so when I had a
lot of experiences working with older
version of cells and this kind of
requires the quite pro longest time of
feeding and culture before experiment
and with cardiomyocytes - you can start
your experiment much faster thank you
renji in rolling out new drugs do you
see the need to get cardiomyocytes from
each patient during clinical trial I'm
going that far but you know there is
some proposal going on but no basically
what we are looking at the cardiac city
is that if it goes out into the local
populace and healthy population are
people who taking drugs specifically
will adversely affect them or not
so just looking for specific acharya
myosin from a specific this is
background it is it is too far at this
stage but it may be coming I don't know
that I'm having a clear answer to you
but it is a very far-fetched custom
thank you now carol has any work been
done on modeling various P
characteristics to predict which ion
channel is being affected so I think
that's a really good question I think we
are just getting started with this and I
think the field is as well so I think
that's something that we can look
forward to seeing in the future Thank
You Carol
now Oksana on your flipper essay so how
do you correct for the different cell
density between wells so typically
typically the cell density is pretty
consistent at least we like it to visit
ray so because as a density is
consistent we have pretty consistent to
be generate and amplitude usually if you
have variation with cell density you
would see big changes in amplitude and
sometimes it in rate or you may not have
beaten and said well at all so in this
case is we just exclude those wells but
typically we don't have to do that and
we don't have ways of normalized in for
different cell density right now
Thank You Oksana renting it was
mentioned that you don't have to do the
thorough QT essay if the drug passes
through SEPA could you explain that more
in detail yes
so the super you know the four buckets
you look at the eye channels and then
based on data that data you do the
modeling and into the pure modeling they
have a prize near risk and all that
comes from the twenty-eight compounds
from the low medium and high preferred
block so if your compound you know goes
to design channel only specific
specified ion channel the first bucket
and then you model that and if you have
a product mixed core which is a it's a
low risk then you know you have to test
for this in the mea to make sure there
is no any unwanted effects and then you
also have to do the the phase one QT
interval there again you want to make
sure that there is no surprises for you
in that state if all of these cannot
clear then you don't have to do a total
cutie si in Phase three and you know
people who are done de it is very
expensive and very time-consuming and
that's we're not the strength of this
people initiative people are trying to
achieve thank you now we've had some
great questions coming in we have time
for just a few more let's go with this
one we'll sit we'll replace need for a
careful clinical assessment of
electrophysiologic effects in phase one
ECG safety studies no that's not the
case I assume it is this about me but if
you look at the four buckets and another
supply initiative slide the fourth but
the last one both bucket is the face
born ECG you still have to do it you
know but you are not only you're not
looking at the TT prolongation there are
some new parameters they're trying to
extract from this critical line another
two key parameters policy specifically
for example j2 t peak and p'pqp end
these two peaks differ you know in the
their response at least you know in a
few positive controls they have tested
that the balance the antenna block no
that's not prolong the jp2 t peak
whereas the hearth block only prolongs
the TP QT and so they are trying to
distinguish in this phase one studies
pure heart blockers are multiple ion
channel blockers obviously you will need
you know balance match and a block in
your drug to go further and to have
adverse leveling not to have a reverse
leveling so yes you know in a silencer
yes you need to do the page one but it's
not going to be the same as what was
done before they are adding some new
parameters to distinguish between the
good and bad drugs
Thank You Renji and let's wrap with this
final question Carol I believe this is
for you how do you know what settings to
use so as we've been doing SI
development and through the validation
process on our new camera and the penta
instrument we have documented the
settings that we used and we've actually
placed them in an 80-page as a protocol
guide for different assays and things
that comes with a screen work software
to give people a good start at the
settings that we've used and then they
can do further asset development from
there so I just wanted to add a little
bit so it's actually pretty fortunate
that exact Satan is not even that
sensitive for the quality of Si so you
can use the range of settings and your
si would be still kind of consistent and
reproducible so we propose some average
settings but they could be modified
without effect on quality of experiment
thank you now big thank you to our
speakers dr. Randy Regan Austin dr.
Pineda lucky a twinkle doctor Oksana
Renko and Carol Crittenden for their
time today and their important research
we would also like to thank lab Rhodes
and our sponsors molecular devices and
European discovery for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I do want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions as a reminder the
questions we did not have time for today
and those that are submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand and
laboratorio via email when it is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us until next time bye bye